ce week-end d'une affaire concernant le
fils du ministre de la Justice a fait le
tour des médias en quête ouverte à
l'encontre du fils d'Eric Dupond-Moretti
soupçonné de violences conjugales il a
été placé en garde à vue réfugiés chez
une voisine qui a alerté légendes
l'accompagne du jeune homme aurait
déclaré avoir été frappé après une
violente dispute celle-ci se serait
plaint de ou de pieds de points et des
coups de sac bouleversé
Eric Dupond-Moretti qui s'était par le
passé engagé contre les violences
conjugales a tenu à réagir à la mise en
examen de son fils en tant que père je
suis dévasté j'ai une pensée pour la
victime chaque violence est intolérable
Raphaël Dupond-Moretti a depuis été
placé sous contrôle judiciaire alors
fils d'Eric Dupond-Moretti mise en
examen pour violence conjugale que
s'est-il vraiment passé
merci à Gauthier Le Bret journaliste
cnews et le costume croisé
je l'adore je l'adore vraiment je
l'adore Gauthier alors merci d'être là
journaliste et c'est vrai que l'effet ce
sont déroulés dans la station de sport
d'hiver de Courchevel on a appris ça ce
weekend que s'est-il passé alors déjà je
pense que c'est important de dire que
c'est pas une affaire politique ça
concerne le fils du ministre exactement
ça le concerne pas lui directement c'est
important de le redire parce que il y a
plein de gens aussi j'ai vu qu'ils ont
fait la malgame voilà voilà et qui sont
son prix un moment moi voilà il est pas
visé directement dans cette affaire donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
absolument pas la faire Adrien qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé donc vous l'avez dit ça
s'est passé dans la station de ski de
Courchevel je dis donc la compagne du
fils d'Éric Dupond-Moretti et bien
accuse son compagnon de violence
conjugales il y a la voisine du couple
qui dit avoir entendu des bruits qui
s'apparentaient à des violences
et elle a donc appelé les gendarmes
ensuite d'ailleurs la compagne du fils
d'Eric Dupond-Moretti s'est réfugié chez
cette voisine les gendarmes sont ensuite
arrivés le fils d'Éric Dupond-Moretti
n'était pas présent sur le lieu au
moment où les gendarmes sont arrivés
c'est livrés ensuite de lui-même à la
gendarmerie il a été mis en garde à vue
ensuite il a été présenté un juge
d'instruction pour une mise en examen en
raison de ses violences conjugales et il
risque donc jusqu'à 3 ans de prison et
45000 euros d'amende puisque c'est moins
de 8 jours d'ttt elle a fait constater
ses blessures après par un médecin
s'accompagne et elle a pris quatre jours
d'été elle dit avoir pris des coups de
pieds des coups de poing et des coups de
sac notamment alors est-ce que le Miss
il apprend en même temps que nous ou
bien ils l'ont prévenu avant de penser
j'imagine que il a appris au moment où
son fils a été placé en garde à vue
peut-être la plaie avant de se rendre de
lui-même au gendarme le ministre il a
réagi alors je vais le citer précisément
pour pas pour pas me tromper sur ce
qu'il a dit il a dit qu'il était dévasté
en tant que père en fait il a trois
réactions en tant que père voilà on voit
la citation s'afficher derrière vous
donc
j'ai une pensée pour violence quelle
qu'elle soit est intolérable en tant que
mi je n'ai cessé de lutter contre les
violences faites aux femmes et pour que
leurs paroles soient prises en compte en
tant que citoyen je demande qu'on
respecte ma vie familiale le débat
politique si il doit y en avoir un c'est
sur son action en tant que ministre pour
lutter contre les violences conjugales
tout de suite voilà tout de suite donc
dévasté en tant que père voilà en tant
que citoyenne du monde à ce qu'on
respecte sa vie privée et en tant que
ministre il dit qu'il lutte contre les
ventes pas fait Jean-Luc Mélenchon
exactement
c'est parfaite il faut quand même le
dire elle est digne elle est parfaite
sous le pied tout le monde bah oui
effectivement on a toujours pas entendu
sur l'affaire 49 toujours pas entendu si
on l'a entendu mais pas de la bonne
manière de la bonne manière aujourd'hui
donc vous m'avez dit 4 jours dit tt pour
la présumée victime présumée c'est c'est
beaucoup mais je vous dis d'un point de
vue légal il y a une barrière à 8 quand
vous risquez plus quand la victime a
plus de 8 jours dit TT et quand donc
elle a moins de 8 jours je voulais dire
à l'instant c'est trois ans de prison et
45000 euros d'amende maximum d'accord
alors c'est vrai que quand on est le
fils de Eric Dupond-Moretti ministre de
la Justice on se dit moi je parle comme
voilà moi je me suis dit comme tous les
citoyens qui doivent nous regarder
est-ce qu'il va pas avoir des passes
droit donc au contraire alors justement
ça va être encore plus compliqué parce
que c'est le petit soupçon tout de suite
qui plane sur le ministre donc le
cabinet du ministre a tout de suite
réagi pour dire que le ministre le garde
des sceaux ne sera en aucun cas informé
des suites judiciaires sur ce dossier
donc voilà et en plus est-ce que ça va
pas être aussi le moyen de est-ce qu'il
va pas aussi les autres qui ont envie
d'y reprendre plus que les autres parce
que bien est-ce qu'ils vont essayer de
voilà de calmer l'affaire comment ça
normalement non non il va pas prendre
moins il va pas prendre plus le but de
la justice c'est qu'elle soit
indépendante du pouvoir politique même
si les juges d'instruction évidemment
dépendent de la chancellerie et du
ministère de la justice mais je vous le
dis pour étouffer cette polémique et
pour pas prêter le flanc aux critiques
le ministère a tout de suite réagi pour
dire que le ministre ne sera en aucun
cas transformer du dossier de son fils
Bernard juste préciser que Monsieur
Dupont-Moretti en sa qualité de ministre
de la Justice justement gardisso il est
au contraire il s'est même battu un peu
contre tous les magistrats il n'a pas la
cote avec les magistrats je crois qu'ils
vont se faire un plaisir d'aligner son
fils
déclaration d'intention mais pour le
moment c'est l'effet rien que les faits
donc il faut rappeler qu'il est présumé
innocent pour le moment le fait qu'il
soit mis en examen placé sous contrôle
judiciaire c'est irréfutable pour ce que
c'est il a quand même été mis en examen
tout de suite monsieur Dupont-Moretti
effectivement sa triple déclaration elle
est on va le dire de mon point de vue
exemplaire rien à dire rien ne prouve
que il y aura ou un acharnement ou une
volonté d'étouffer l'affaire pour le
moment en tout cas c'est irréprochable
sur le plan judiciaire Cyril il faut le
dire parce que parfois dans les temps
passés il y a eu des affaires que
politiquement on essaie d'écraser comme
ça là pour le moment il y a rien du tout
c'est un contexte tendu de séparation
une affaire très compliqué effectivement
il y a eu un constat quatre jours dit tt
pour le moment tout se déroule tout à
fait normalement comme si c'était un
justiciable comme un autre d'accord
juste ils sont il a le droit de voir ça
de voir son ancienne campagne son océan
de campagne ou pas du tout pas non
certainement pas certainement pas
imagine que sur le contrôle judiciaire
ah oui le contrôle judiciaire c'est pas
une liberté donc faut aller au
commissariat ou à l'agenda et tous les X
du mois etc il y a il y a plusieurs
contraintes on imagine que non il pourra
pas croiser sa son ancienne compagne
alors sur les réseaux sociaux ça a été
bien entendu un déferlement sur cette
affaire et beaucoup ont fait le lien
donc entre le fils et le père certains
critiquaient la réaction du ministre ont
appelé qu'en tant qu'avocat il a parfois
adnié la parole des femmes qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez euh
non moi je trouve que pour l'instant
c'est très ambigieux ce serait très
malsain je trouve de réagir sur son
tweet que je le trouve plutôt exemplaire
et assez digne donc ouais c'est vrai
qu'il a défendu des gens qu'on peut
imaginer un défendable nous aujourd'hui
en 2023 mais il est avocat aujourd'hui
il est gardé sauts donc voilà moi je
pense qu'il faut respecter sa douleur de
père et pour l'instant laisser faire la
justice de manière indépendante le plus
indépendante possible alors maintenant
donc ça va être ça va être assez long
cette affaire
ben j'imagine oui ça va être ça va
prendre le temps ça va être assez long
ça dépend des fois regardez l'affaire 4
nains il a reconnu l'effet tout de suite
il a été tout de suite présenté un juge
ça a été traité très rapidement donc
encore une fois c'est du cas par cas là
je sais pas je peux pas vous dire si ça
va prendre du temps ou si ça va être
très très rapidement de son avocat non
je crois pas en tout cas il sait pas
présenté dans les médias et il a pas
fait parler de lui